[Music]  you probably read about this the  government has now ordered nasa to cut  all of its expensive space projects like  the mars rover did you know that yeah  and of course there's also been talk in  the last couple of months about chopping  pbs's budget for shows like sesame  street  [Music]  yeah well with that in mind nasa and pbs  have decided to combine forces  come up with an amazing teaching tool  for young minds it's here with us  tonight they're letting us test it  i don't know why  please welcome ladies and gentlemen the  mars grover  [Applause]  [Music]  far  [Music]  [ __ ] okay well  thank you mars grover that was terrific  it's nice to have oh  look at that  he's coming hi  [Music]  wow this is exciting  how are you mars grover  i am up  now i am down yeah that's great  up  down yeah okay thanks that's that's  terrific  yeah  oh hi how are you  andy  audios  great audience  grover you're just sucking up to the  audience  grover shameless  we have a great show tonight